The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Just a reminder,
drop day is tomorrow.
So if you were thinking
about dropping the course
or in danger of a bad
grade or something,
tomorrow's the last
chance to bail out.
Last time we began our
discussion on probability
with the Monty Hall game--
the Monty Hall problem.
And as part of the analysis,
we made assumptions
of the form that given that
Carol placed the prize in box
1, the probability that
the contestant chooses
box 1 is 1/3.
Now, this is an
example of something
that's called a
conditional probability.
And that's what we're
going to study today.
Now, in general,
you have something
like the conditional
probability that an event, A,
happens given that some
other event, B, has already
taken place.
And you write that down as
a probability of A given B.
And both A and B are events.
Now, the example
from Monty Hall--
and actually, we had
several-- but you
might have B being
the event that Carol
places the prize in box 1.
And A might be the event that
the contestant chooses box 1.
And we assumed for
the Monty Hall game
that the probability of
A given B in this case
was 1/3 third because
the contestant didn't
know where the prize was.
Now in general, there's
a very simple formula
to compute the probability
of A given B. In fact, we'll
treat it as a definition.
Assuming the probability of B
is non-zero than the probability
of A given B is just the
probability of A and B
happening, both happening,
divided by the probability
of B happening.
And you can see why this makes
sense when the picture-- say
this is our sample space.
And let this be the
event, A, and this
be the event, B. Now we're
conditioning on the fact
that B happened.
Now once we've
conditioned on that,
all this stuff outside of
B is no longer possible.
All those outcomes are no longer
in the space of consideration.
The only outcomes left
are in B. So in some sense
we've shrunk the
sample space to be B.
And all we care about is the
probability that A happens
inside this new sample space.
And that is, we're asking the
probability 1 of these outcomes
happens given that this
is the sample space.
Well, this is just A
intersect B because you still
have to have A happen, but
now you're inside of B.
And then we divide
by probability of B.
So we normalize this
to be probability one.
OK.
Because we're
saying B happened--
we're conditioning on that.
Therefore, the probability
of these outcomes must be 1.
So we divide by the probability
of B. So we normalize.
This now becomes-- the
probability of A given B
is this share of B
weighted by the outcomes.
OK.
All right.
For example then, what's the
probability of B given B?
what's that equal?
1.
OK.
Because we said it happened-- so
it happens with probability 1.
Or, using the formula, that's
just probability of B and B
divided by probability
of B. Well, that
equals the probability
of B divided
by the probability
of B, which is 1.
All right.
Any questions about
the definition
of the conditional probability?
Very simple.
And it's easy to work
with using the formulas.
Now, there's a nice
rule called the product
rule, which follows from
the definition very simply.
The product rule says that
the probability of A and B
for two events is equal
to the probability of B
times the probability
of A given B.
And that's just follow
straightforwardly
from this definition.
Just multiply by probability
of B on both sides.
All right.
So now you have a
rule of computing
a probability of two events
simultaneously happening.
So for example, in the
Monty Hall problem,
what's the probability
that Carol places
the prize in box one and that's
the box the contestant chooses?
All right?
So if we took A and B
as defined up there,
that's the probability that
Carol places it in box one
and the contestant chose it.
Well, that's the probability
that the contestant chooses
it is 1/3 times the probability
that Carol put it there,
given the contestant chose
it, or actually, vice versa,
Is 1/9.
OK?
And this extends to more events.
It is called the
general product rule.
So if you want to compute
the probability of A1 and A2
and all the way up to An, that's
simply the probability of a 1
happening all by itself times
the probability of A2 given A1
times-- well, I'll do the next
one-- times the probability
of A3 given A1 and A2, dot,
dot dot, times, finally,
the probability of An
given all the others.
So that starts to look a
little more complicated.
But it gives you a handy way
of computing the probability
that an intersection
of events takes place.
I do This is proved by induction
on n, just taking that rule
and using induction on n.
It's not hard.
But we won't go through it.
All right.
Let's do some examples.
We'll start with an easy one.
Say you're playing
a playoff series
and you're going to
play best 2 out of 3.
All right.
So you have a best
2 out of 3 series.
So whoever wins the first two
games, best two out of three
wins.
And say you're told that
the probability of winning
the first game is 1/2.
So the teams are matched
50-50 for the first game.
But then you're told that the
probability of winning a game
after a victory is higher.
It's 2/3.
So the probability of
winning immediately
after a game following
a win is two thirds.
And similarly, the probability
of winning after a loss is 1/3.
All right.
And the idea here is
that you win a game,
you're sort of psyched,
you've got momentum,
and going into the next day
you're more likely to win.
Similarly, if you lost
you're sort of down
and the other guy has a
better chance of beating you.
Now, what we're going
to try to figure out
is the probability
of winning the series
given you won the first game.
All right?
Now, conditional
probability comes up
in two places in this problem.
Anybody tell me places
where it's come up?
So I got the problem statement
and the that's the goal
is to figure out the probability
you win the series given
you won the first game.
So what's one place
conditional probability
is entering into this problem?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The
probability changes
depending on the result
of the previous game.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
The probability of winning
any particular game
is influenced by
the previous game.
So you're using conditional
probability there.
All right.
And where else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you have to take
into account [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's interesting.
That will be another question
we're going to look at.
What's the probability
of playing three games?
Yep.
That's one.
OK.
Well, the question
we're after, what's
the probability of
winning the series given
that you won the first game.
We're going to compute a
conditional probability there.
So it's coming up in a
couple of places here.
All right.
Let's figure this out.
It's easy to do given
the tree method.
So let's make the tree for this.
So we have possibly three games
there's game one, game two,
and game three.
Game one, you can win or lose.
There's two branches.
Game two you can win or lose.
And now, game three-- well, it
doesn't even take place here.
But it does here.
You can win or lose here.
And you could win or lose here.
And here the series is over.
So there is no game
three in that case.
The probabilities are
next we put a probability
of every branch here.
Game one is 50-50.
What's the probability
you take this branch?
2/3, because you're on the path
where you won the first game.
You win the second
game with 2/3.
You lose with 1/3.
Now here you're on the path
where you lost the first game.
So this has 1/3
and this has 2/3.
All right?
And then lastly, what's
the probability I have
the win on the third game here?
1/3, because I just
lost the last game.
That's all I'm conditioning on.
So that becomes 1/3.
And this is 2/3 now.
And then here I just won a game.
So I've got 2/3 and 1/3.
All right.
So I got all the probabilities.
And now I need to figure out
for the sample points what's
their probability.
So this sample point
we'll call win-win.
This sample point
is win-lose-win.
This one's win-lose-lose.
Then we have lose-win-win,
lose-win-lose,
and then lose-lose.
So I got six sample points.
And let's figure out the
probability for each one.
Now remember the rule we
had for the tree method.
I just multiply these things.
Well, in fact, the
reason we have that rule
is because that is the
same as the product rule.
Because what I'm
asking here to compute
the probability of this guy
is-- so the product rule gives
the probability of a win-win
scenario-- win the first game,
win the second game.
By the product rule
is the probability
that I win the first game
times the probability
that I win the second game
given that I won the first game.
That's what the
product rule says.
Probability I win the
first game is 1/2 times
the probability I
win the second given
that I won the first is 2/3.
So that equals 1/3.
So what we're doing
here now is giving you
the formal justification for
that rule that we had last time
and that you'll always use--
is the probability of a sample
point is the product
of the probabilities
on the edges leading to it.
It's just the product rule.
Now the next
example is this one.
And here we're going to use the
general product rule to get it.
The probability of win-lose-win
by the general product rule
is the probability that
you win the first game
times the probability you
lose the second game given
the that you win the first
times the probability you
win the third given what?
What am I given on
the product rule?
Won the first, lost the second.
All right.
Well, now we can
fill in the numbers.
The probability I win
the first is a 1/2.
The probability that
I lose the second
given that I won the
first, that's 1/3.
And then this one
here, the probability
that I win the third
given that I won the first
and lost the second,
that simplifies
the probability I win the third
given that I lost the second.
Doesn't matter what
happened on the first.
And that's 1/3.
So this is 1/2 times
1/3 times 1/3 is 118.
And that's 1/18.
And it's just the product
because the product rule
saying product of
the first probability
times this one, which is
the conditional probability
of being here times
this one, which
is a conditional probability if
these events happened before.
Any questions about that?
Very simple to
do, which is good.
Yeah.
Is there a question?
OK.
All right.
So let's fill in the
other probabilities here.
I got 1/2, 1/3, and 2/3.
That's 1/9.
Same thing here is 1/9.
This is 1/18 and 1/3.
OK.
So those are the probabilities
in the sample points.
Now, to compute the probability
of winning the series given
that we won the first game,
let's define the events here.
So A be the event that
we win the series.
B will be the event that
we win the first game.
And I want to compute the
probability of A given B.
And we use our formula.
Where's the formula for that?
It's way back over there.
The probability of A
given B is the probability
of both happening, the
probability of A and B
divided by the probability of B.
So now I just have to
compute these probabilities.
So to do that I got to figure
out which sample points are
in A and B here.
So let's write that down.
There's A, B, A
and B. All right.
So A is the event that
we win the series.
Now this sample point qualifies,
that one does, and this one.
B is the event we
won the first game.
And that's these
three sample points.
And then A and B
intersect B is these two.
All right.
So for each event
that I care about
I figure out which sample
points are in that event.
And now I just add
the probabilities up.
So what's the
probability of A and B?
7/18.
1/3 plus 1/18.
What's the probability of B?
Yeah.
1/2, 9/18.
I got these three points.
So this'll be 1/3 third plus
1/18 plus the extra one, 1/9.
So I've got 7/18 over 9/18.
7/9 is the answer.
So the probability
we win the Series
given we won the
first game is 7/9.
Any questions?
We're going to do this same
thing about 10 different times.
OK?
And it will look a little
different each time maybe.
But it's the same idea.
And the beauty here is
it's really easy to do.
I'm going to give you a
lot of confusing examples.
But really, if you just do this
is it's going to be very easy.
All right.
Somebody talked about the
series lasting three games.
What's the probability the
series lasts three games?
Can anybody look at
that and tell me?
1/3 because what you would do
is add up these three sample
points.
And it's the opposite
of these two.
So it's 2/3 chance of two games,
a 1/3 chance of three games.
So it's not likely
to go three games.
All right.
So to this point,
we've seen examples
of a conditional
probability where
it's A given B where A follows
B, like, we're told B happened.
Now what's the chance of
A. And A is coming later.
The probability of
winning today's game
given that you won yesterday's
game, the probability
of winning the series given
you already won the first game.
Next, we're going to look
at the opposite scenario
where the events are
reversed in order.
The probability that
you won the first game
given that you won the series.
All right.
Now, this is
inherently confusing
because if you're
trying to figure--
if you know you
the series, well,
you already know what
happened in the first game
because it's been played.
So how could there be
any probability there?
It happened.
Well, so what the meaning
is is over all the times
where the series
was played, sort
of what fraction of
the time did the team
that won the series win
the first game is one
way you could think about it.
Or, maybe you just don't know.
The game was played.
You know you won the series.
But you don't know who
won the first game.
And so you could think of a
probability still being there.
Now when you think about it,
it gets me confused still.
But just think about
it like the math.
It's the same formula.
OK.
It doesn't matter which
happened first in time.
You use the same mathematics.
In fact, they give a special
name these kinds of things.
They're called a postieri
conditional probabilities.
It's a fancy name for just
saying that things are out
of order in time.
All right?
So it's a probability of B given
A where B precedes A in time.
All right?
So it's the same math.
It's just they're out of order.
So let's figure
out the probability
that you won the first game
given that you want the series.
Let's figure it out.
So I want probability of B
given A now for this example.
Well, it's just the
probability of B and A
over the probability of A.
We already computed the
probability of A and B.
That's 1/3 plus 1/18.
what's the probability
of A, the probability
of winning the first game?
1/2.
It's those three sample points
and they better add up to 1/2
because we sort of said, the
probability of the first game's
1/2.
So that's over
1/2, which is 9/18.
Well this was 7/18 over 9/18.
It's 7/9.
So the probability of
winning the first game given
that you won series is 7/9.
Anybody notice anything
unusual about that answer here?
It's the same as the
answer over there.
Is that a theorem?
No.
The probability of A
given B is not always
the probability of B given
A. It was in this case.
It is not always true.
In fact, we could
make a simple example
to see why that's
not always the case.
All right.
So say here's your sample space.
And say that this
is B and this is
A. What's the probability
of A given B in this case?
1.
If you're in B-- wait.
No.
It's not 1.
What's the probability of
A given B If I got some--
probably less than 1.
Might be I've drawn it as
1/3 third if it was uniform.
But in this case, the
probability of A given B
is less than 1.
What's the probability
of B given A?
1, because if I'm in A I'm
definitely in B. All right.
So that's an example where
they would be different.
And that's the generic
case is they're different.
All right?
When are they equal because
they were equal in this case?
What makes them equal?
Let's see.
When does the
probability of A given B
equal a probability
of B given A?
Let's see.
Well, If I plug-in
the formula, this
equals the probability of A and
B over the probability of B.
That equals the probability of
B and A over a probability of A.
So when are those equal?
Yeah.
When probability A equals
probability B. All right.
So that's one case.
What's the other case?
Yeah-- when it's 0.
Probability-- there's
no intersection.
Probability of A
intersect B is 0.
That's the other case.
All right.
But usually these
conditions won't
apply-- just happened to in
this example by coincidence.
Any questions about that?
All right.
Yeah.
So the math is the same with
a postieri probabilities.
It's really, really easy.
All right.
So let's do another simple
example that'll start to maybe
be a little more confusing.
Say we've got two coins.
One of them is a fair coin.
And by that, I mean the
probability comes up
heads is the same as
the probability comes up
tails is 1/2.
The other one is an unfair coin.
And in this case, that
means it's always heads.
The probability of heads is 1.
The probability of tails is 0.
All right?
I've got two such coins here.
All right.
Here is the unfair
coin-- heads and heads.
Actually, they make these things
look like quarters sometimes.
Here's the fair coin--
heads and tails.
All right.
Now suppose I pick one of
these at random, 50-50,
I pick one of
these things, and I
flip it, which I'm doing behind
my back, and lo and behold,
it comes out and,
you see a heads.
What's the probability
I'm holding the fair coin?
I picked the coin,
50-50, behind my back.
So one answer is, I picked the
fair coin with 50% probability.
But then I flipped
it behind my back
and I showed you the
result. And you see heads.
Of course, if I'd
have shown you tails,
You would have known for
sure it was the fair coin
because that's the only
one with the tails.
But you don't know for sure now.
You see a heads.
What's the probability this is
the fair coin given that you
saw a heads after the flip?
How many people think 1/2?
After all, I picked it
with probability 1/2.
How many people think
it's less than 1/2?
Good.
OK.
Somebody even said 1/3.
Does that sound right?
A couple people like 1/3.
OK.
All right.
Now, part of what
makes this tricky
is I told you I picked the
coin with 50% probability.
But then I gave you information.
So I've conditioned the problem.
And so this is one
of those things
you could have an
ask Marilyn about.
Is it 1/2 or is it 1/3?
Because I picked
it with 50% chance,
what does the
information do for you?
Now, I'll give you a clue.
Bobo might have written
in and said it's 1/2.
And his proof is that
three other mathematicians
agreed with him.
[LAUGHTER]
All right?
OK.
So let's figure it out.
And really it's very simple.
It's just drawing out
the tree and computing
the conditional probability.
So we're going to do the same
thing over and over again
because it just works
for every problem.
Of course, you could imagine
debating this for awhile,
arguing with somebody.
Is it 1/2 or 1/3?
Much simpler just to do it.
So the first thing is we
have, which coin is picked?
So it could be
fair-- and I told you
that happens with
probability 1/2-- or unfair,
which is also 1/2.
Then we have the flip.
The fair coin is
equally likely to be
heads or tails, each with 1/2.
The unfair coin, guaranteed
to be heads, probability 1.
All right.
Now we get the sample
point outcomes.
It's fair in heads with
the probability 1/4,
fair in tails,
probability 1/4, unfair
in heads, probability 1/2.
Now we define the
events of interest.
A is going to be that
we chose the fair coin.
And B is at the
result, is heads.
And of course what
I want to know
is the probability that I
chose the fair coin given
that I saw a heads.
So to do that we
plug in our formula.
That's just the
probability of A and B
over the probability
of B. And to compute
that I got to figure out
the probability of A and B
and the probability of B.
So I'll make my diagram.
A here, B here, A
and B. A is the event
I chose the fair coin.
That's these guys.
B is the event the
result is heads.
That's this one and this one.
And A intersect B,
That's the only point.
So this is really
easy to compute now.
What's the probability
of A and B?
1/4.
It's just that sample point.
What's the probability of B?
3/4, 1/4 plus 1/2.
So the probability
of A given B is 1/3.
Really simple to
answer this question.
Just don't even think about it.
Just write down the tree
when you get these things.
So much easier just to
write the tree down.
All right.
Now the key here is we
knew the probability
of picking the fair
coin in the first place.
Maybe it's worth
writing down what
happens if that's a variable--
sum variable P. Let's do that.
For example, what if I hadn't
told you the probability
that I picked the fair coin?
I just picked one
and flipped it.
Think that'll change the answer?
It should because you got
to plug something in there
for the 1/2 for this to work.
So let's see what happens.
Say I picked the fair
coin with probability
P and the unfair
coin with 1 minus P.
And this is the same
heads and tails, 1/2, 1/2.
Heads, the probability 1.
Well now, instead of 1/4
I get P over 2 up here.
And this is now 1
minus P instead of 1/2.
So the probability of A given
B is the probability of A and B
is p over 2.
And the probability
of B is P over 2
plus 1 minus P. That's P over
2 up top, one minus P over 2,
and that is all
multiplied by-- what am I
going to multiply-- 2 here.
I'll get P over 2 minus P.
So the probability with which
I picked the coin to start with
impacts the answer here.
For example, what if I picked
the unfair coin for sure?
That would be P being 0.
Well, the probability that
I picked the fair coin
is 0 over 2, which is 0.
All right though-- even
know I showed you the heads,
there's no chance it was the
fair coin because I picked
the unfair coin for sure.
Same thing if I picked
the fair coin for sure,
better be the case this is 1.
So I get 1 over 2 minus 1.
It's 1.
Any questions?
So it's important you know
the probability I picked
the fair coin to start with.
Otherwise, you
can't go anywhere.
All right.
What if I do the same game?
Pick a coin with probability p.
But now I flip it K times.
Say I flip it 100 times.
And every time it
comes up heads.
I mean you're pretty sure you
got the unfair coin because you
never saw a tails.
Right?
So let's do that.
Let's compute that scenario.
So instead of a single
heads I get K straight heads
and no tails.
This would happen with
1 over 2 to the K.
This would happen with 1
minus 1 over 2 to the K.
So this is now p over 2 to
the K. This is now P1 minus 2
to the minus K.
Let's recompute
the probabilities.
I'm going somewhere where this.
Wait a minute.
So now we're
looking at the event
that B is K straight heads.
Come up.
And I want to know
the probability
that I picked the fair coin
given that it just never comes
up tails.
The math is the same.
The probability now that
I picked the fair coin
and got k straight
heads is just p times 2
to the minus K. The probability
that I got K straight heads is
P times 2 to the minus
K plus the chance
I picked the unfair
coin, which is 1 minus P.
And if I multiply top
and bottom by 2 to the K,
I get P over P plus
to the K 1 minus B.
All right.
So it gets very unlikely that
I've got the fair coin here
as K gets big.
Like if K is 100 I got
a big number down here.
And basically it's
0 chance-- close
to 0 chance of the fair coin.
But now say I do the
following experiment.
I don't tell you P.
But I pull a coin out
and 100 flips in
a row it's heads.
Which coin do you think I have?
I flipped it 100 straight times
and it's heads every time.
Yeah.
There's not enough information.
You don't know.
What do you want to say?
You want to say
it's the unfair coin
but you have no idea because I
might have picked the fair coin
with probability 1, in which
case it is the fair coin
and it just was unlucky
that it came up heads
100 times in a row.
But it could be.
So you could say nothing if you
don't know the probability P.
Because sure enough, if
I plug in P being 1 here,
that wipes out the 2 to the K
and I just get probability 1.
OK?
All right.
Now when this comes
up in practice
is with things like polling.
Like, we just had an election.
And people do poles
ahead of time.
And they sample
thousands of voters
from 1% of the population.
And they say, OK,
that 60% of the people
are going to vote Republican.
And they might have a margin of
error, three points, whatever
that means.
And we'll figure
that out next week.
What does that tell you about
the electorate as a whole--
the population if they sample 1%
at random, 60% are Republican.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
The options you have,
is it all heads or
is it all tails?
It should be one
option all heads
and another option
at least one tails.
PROFESSOR: You're right.
Oops.
All right.
At least one tail for this one.
Yeah.
Good.
That is true.
OK.
Any questions
about that example?
OK.
Now we're back to the
election and there's
a pole that says they sampled
1% of the population at random
and 60% said they're
going to vote Republican.
And the margin of error
is 3% or something.
What does that tell you about
the population of the country?
Nothing.
That's right.
It is what it is.
All you can conclude is
that either the population
is close to 60% Republican
or you were unlucky
in the 1% you sample.
That's what you can conclude
because the population really
is fixed in this case.
It is what it is.
There's no randomness
in the population.
All right?
So you have next
week for recitation.
You're going to design a
pole and work through how
to calculate the margin
of error and work
through what that
really means in terms
of what the population is like.
Now of course, if it comes
out 100 straight times heads,
you've got to be really
unlucky to have the fair coin.
And the same thing
with designing the poll
if you're way off.
Any questions about that?
OK.
The next example comes up
all the time in practice.
And that's with medical testing.
Maybe I'll leave-- no.
I'll take that down.
We know that now.
Now in this case--
in fact, this is
a question we had on the
final exam a few years ago.
And there's a good chance
this kind of question's
going to be on the
final this year.
There's a disease out there.
And you can have a test for it.
But like most medical
tests, they're not perfect.
Sometimes when it says you've
got the disease you really
don't.
And if it ways you don't
have it, you really do.
So in this case,
we're going to assume
that 10% of the population has
the disease, whatever it is.
You don't get
symptoms right away.
So you have this test.
But if you have the disease
there is a 10% chance
that the test is negative.
And this is called
a false negative,
because the test comes back
negative but it's wrong,
because you have the disease.
And similarly, if you
have the disease--
or sorry-- if you
don't have the disease,
there's a 30% chance that
the test comes back positive.
And it's called a false positive
because it came back positive,
but you don't have it.
So the test is pretty good.
Right?
It's 10% false negative right,
30% false positive right.
Now say you select a random
person and they test positive.
What you want to know
is the probability
they have the disease given
that it's a random person.
So actually, this came
up in my personal life.
Many years ago when my wife
was pregnant with Alex,
she was exposed to somebody
with TB here at MIT.
And she took the test.
And it came back positive.
Now the bad thing--
TB's a bad thing.
You don't want to get it.
But the medicine for it
you take for six months.
And she was worried
about taking medicine
for six months when she's
pregnant because who
knows what the TB medicine
does kind of thing
if you have a baby.
So she asked the doc, what's
the probability I really
have the disease?
The doc doesn't know.
The doc maybe could give
you some of these steps,
10% false negative,
30% false positive.
But it tested positive.
So they just normally
give you the medicine.
So say this was the story.
What would you say?
What do you think?
How many people think that
it's a least a 70% chance
you got the disease?
She tested positive
and it's only
got a 30% false positive rate.
Anybody?
So you don't think
she's likely to have it.
How many people think
it's better than 50-50
you have the disease?
A few.
How many people
think less than 50%.
A bunch.
Yeah.
You're right, in fact.
Let's figure out the answer.
It's easy to do.
So A is the event the
person has the disease.
And B is the event that
the person tests positive.
And of course what
we want to know
is the probability you
have the disease given
that you tested positive.
And that's just the probability
of both events divided
by the probability
of testing positive.
So let's figure that
out by drawing the tree.
So first, do you
have the disease?
And it's yes or no.
And let's see.
The probability of
having the disease, what
is that for a random person?
10%.
that the stat.
So it's-- actually,
we'll call it 0.1.
And 9.9 you don't have it.
And then there's the test.
Well, you can be
positive or negative.
Now if you have
the disease, there
is a-- the chance you
test negative is 10%, 0.1.
Therefore there's a 90%
chance you test positive.
Now if, you don't
have the disease,
you could test either way.
If you don't have the
disease there's a 30% chance
you test positive.
30 here and 70% percent
chance you're negative.
Now we can compute each
sample point probability.
This one is 0.1
times 0.9 is 0.09.
0.1 times 1 is 0.01.
0.9 and 0.3 is 0.27.
0.9 and 0.7 is 0.63.
So all sample points
are figured out.
Now we figure out which sample
points are in which sets.
So we have event A, event B,
and A intersect B. Let's see.
A is the event you
have the disease.
That's these guys.
B is the event
you test positive.
That's this one and this one.
A intersect B is just this one.
All right.
We're almost done.
Let's just figure
out the probability
you have the disease.
What's the probability
of A intersect B?
0.09.
It's just that one sample point.
What's the probability
that you tested positive?
0.36.
Yeah.
0.09 plus 0.27, which is 0.36.
So I got 0.09 over 0.36 is 1/4.
Wow.
That seems bizarre.
Right?
You've got a test, 10%
percent false negative,
30% false positive.
Yet, when you test positive
there's only a 25% chance
you have the disease.
So maybe you don't
take the medicine.
So if there's risk
both ways, probably
don't have the disease.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
disease change
because you've
already been exposed
to somebody that has it?
PROFESSOR: That's a
great point, great point,
because there's
additional information
conditioning this in the
personal example I cited.
You were exposed to somebody.
So we need to condition
on that as well, which
raises the chance
you have the disease.
That's a great point.
Yeah.
Just like in the-- well, we
haven't got to that example.
Do another example with
that exact kind of thing
is very important.
All right.
So this is sort of
paradoxical that it
looks like a pretty good
test-- low false positive,
full false negatives, but
likely be wrong, at least if it
tells you have the disease.
In fact, let's figure out.
What's the probability
that the test is correct?
What's the probability the
test is right in general?
72%.
Let's see.
So it would be 0.09 plus 0.63.
72%.
So it's likely to be right.
But if it tells you
you have the disease
it's likely to be wrong.
It's hard.
Why is this happening?
Why does it come out that way?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Then there is
only a 1 in 64 chance
that you have the disease.
So if it comes back
negative, then it's
a pretty good indication
that you're OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
If it comes back negative than
it really is doing very well.
That's right.
But why is it when it
comes back positive
that you're unlikely to have
the disease if it's a good test.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The
disease is so rare.
PROFESSOR: The
Absolutely.
This number here is so small.
And that's what's doing it.
Because if you look at how
many people have the disease
and test positive, it's 0.09.
So many people don't
have the disease
that even with a small false
positive rate, this number
swamps out that number.
In fact, imagine
nobody had the disease.
You'd have a 0 here.
All right?
And then you would always be
wrong if you said you had it.
OK?
That's good.
OK.
This comes up in weather
prediction, the same paradox.
For example, say you're
trying to predict
the weather for Seattle.
Sometimes it seems
like this in Boston.
And you just say,
it's going to rain.
Forget all the fancy weather
forecasting stuff, the radar,
and all the rest.
Just say it's going
to rain tomorrow.
You're going to be right
almost all the time.
All right?
And in fact, if you
try to do fancy stuff,
you're probably going to
be wrong more of the time.
All right.
For example, in this
case, if you just
say the person does not have the
disease, forget the lab test.
Just come back with negative.
How often are you right?
90% of the time you're right.
Much better than the test
you paid a lot of money for.
I see.
You've got to be careful
what you're looking for,
how you measure the value
of a test or a prediction.
Because presumably
the one you paid
for is better, even though
accurate less of the time.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So For the rest of
today we're going
to do three more paradoxes.
And in each case
they're going to expose
a flaw in our intuition
about probability.
But the good news
is in each case it's
easy to get the right answer.
Just stick with the math and
try not to think about it.
Now the first example
is a game involving
dice that's called carnival dice
that you can find in carnivals
and you can also
find in casinos.
It's a pretty popular
game, actually.
So the way it works
is as follows.
The player picks a number from
1 to 6-- we'll call it N--
and then rolls three dice.
And let's say they're fair
and mutually independent.
We haven't talked
about independent.
So they're fair dice.
For now, normal
dice-- nothing fishy.
And the player wins if and
only if the number he picked
comes up on at least
one of the dice.
So you either win
or you lose the game
depending on if your lucky
number came up at least once.
Now you've got three dice,
each of which has a 1
in 6 chance of coming
up a winner for you.
So how many people think
this is a fair game-- you
got a 50-50 chance of
winning-- three dice, each 1/6
chance of winning?
Anybody think it's
not a fair game?
A bunch of you.
How many people think it
is a fair game-- 50-50?
A few.
All right.
Well, let's figure it out.
And instead of doing
the tree method, which
we know we're
supposed to do, we're
just going to wing it, which
is always seems easier to do.
If you're in the Casino
you want to just wing it
instead of taking your napkin
out and drawing a tree.
So the claim, question mark, is
the probability you win in 1/2.
And the proof, question
mark, is you let Ai
be the event that the i-th die
comes up N. And i is 1 to 3
here.
So then you say, OK.
The probability I win is
the probability of A1--
I could win that
way-- or A2, or A3.
All I need is one of the
die to come up my way.
And that is the
probability of A1
plus the probability of A2
plus the probability of A3.
And each die wins for
me with probability 1/6.
And that is then 1/2.
So that's a proof that we
win with probability of 1/2.
What do you think?
Any problems with that proof?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well
that's a great point.
Yeah.
So if I extended this
nice proof technique
I couldn't have probability of
7/6 of winning with seven die.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're very close.
I didn't technically
assume that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: They could double up.
Yeah.
There's no intersection
in the events.
In fact, there is
intersection because there's
a chance I rolled
all six-- all Ns.
Say N is 6.
I could roll all sixes
and then each of these
would be a winner.
But I don't get to
count them separately.
Then I only win
once in that case.
In other words, all of
these could turned on
at the same time.
There's an intersection here.
So this rule does not hold.
I need the Ai to be
disjoined for this
to be true-- the
events to be disjoined.
And they're not
disjoined because there's
a sample point were
two or more of the die
could come up the same
being a winner, which
means the same sample
point, namely all die are N,
comes up in each of these three.
So they're not disjoined.
Now what's the principal
you used two weeks ago when
you did cardinality of a set--
cardinality of a union of sets?
Inclusion, exclusion.
And the same thing
needs to be done here.
So let's do that.
And then we'll figure out
the actual probability.
So this is a fact based on the
inclusion, exclusion principle.
The probability of A1,
union A2, union A3,
is just what you think it would
be from inclusion, exclusion.
It's a probability of
A1 plus a probability
of A2 plus the
probability of A3 minus
the pairwise intersections.
A1 intersect A3 minus
probability of A2 intersect A3.
And is there anything else?
Plus, the probably of
all of them matching.
OK.
So the proof is
really the same proof
you use for inclusion,
exclusion with sets.
The only difference is that
in a probability space,
we have weights on the elements.
And the weight corresponds
to the probability.
So in fact, if you were drawing
the sample space, say here's A1
and here's A2, and here's A3.
Well, you need to add the
probabilities here, here,
and here.
Then you subtract off the double
counting from here, from here,
and from here.
And then you add back again
what you subtracted off
too much there.
Same proof, it's just your
have weights on the elements
of probabilities.
All right.
So let's figure out
the right probability.
That's 1/6, 1/6, 1/6.
What's the probability
of the first two die
matching-- both of them?
1/36.
We'll talk more about
why that is next time.
But there's a 6 for A1 then
given that 1/6 for the second
die matching.
So it's 1/6 times
1/6 minus the 1/36.
1/36, the chance that all three
match is 1/216 or 6 cubed.
So when you add all that up you
get the 0.421 and some more.
So the chance of
winning this game
is 41% which makes it a
worst game in the casino.
It is hard to find a
worse game than this.
Roulette, much better.
We'll study Roulette in the
last lecture-- much better game.
And even that's a
terrible game to play.
So it looks like an easy game.
There's a quick proof
that it's 50-50.
But it's horrible odds
against the house.
Now, this is a nice
example because it
shows how a rule you had for
computing the cardinality
of a set gives you
the probability.
All right.
In fact, all the set laws you
learned a couple weeks ago
work for probability
spaces the same way.
And there were several
of those in homework
that you just had
the last problem set.
Any questions about that?
OK.
Now in addition, all those
set laws you did also
work for conditional
probabilities.
For example, this is true.
The probability of A union B
given C-- whoops-- given C,
is the probability of A given
C plus the probability of B
given C minus the intersection,
A intersect B given
C. In other words, take any
probability rule you have
and condition everything on an
event, C, and it still works.
And the proof is not hard.
You can go through
each individual law
but it all comes out to be fine.
All right.
You have to be a little
careful though because you
got to remember which
side you're doing,
which what you're putting on
either side of the bar here.
For example, what
about this one?
Is this true?
Claim.
Let's take-- say C
and D are disjoined.
Is this true?
Then the probability
of A conditioned
on C union D. So given
that either C or D is true,
does that equal the
probability of A given C
plus probability of A given D?
We know that if I swapped
all these, it's true.
The probability of C union
D when C and D are disjoined
is the probability that C given
A plus the probability of D
given A. That I just claimed.
And what about this way?
Can I swap things around?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
would C union D be 0?
PROFESSOR: If C and
D are disjoined,
C union D would just be C union
D. But you're not a good point.
What if C and D are disjoined?
That's a good example.
Let's draw that.
Let's look at that case.
So we've got a
sample space here.
And you've got C
here and D here.
And just for fun, let's make A
be here-- include all of them.
What's the probability-- is
this going to do what I want?
Yeah.
What's the probability
of A given C?
1.
If I'm in C I'm in A.
A is everything here.
So the probability
of A given C is one.
What's the probability
of A given D?
1.
All right.
Well, this is a
problem because I
can't have the probability ot--
what's the probably of A given
C union D?
Well, it can't be 2.
Right?
It's 1.
They are not equal.
So you cannot do those set
rules on the right side
of the conditioning bar.
You can do them on the
left, not on the right.
All right.
So this is not true.
Now nobody would do this.
Right?
I mean, the probability of-- not
that it's-- see this example?
This you just would never
make this mistake again seeing
that example.
Everybody understand
the example,
how it's clearly
not always the case
that probability
of A given C union
D is a probability of A given C
plus probability of A given D?
Because now I'm going to show
you an example where you're
going to swear it's true.
All right?
And this is a real life example.
Many years ago now there was
a sex discrimination suit
at Berkeley.
There was a female professor
in the math department.
And she was denied tenure.
And she filed a lawsuit
against Berkeley
alleging sex discrimination.
Said she wasn't tenured
because she's a woman.
Now, unfortunately
sex discrimination
is a problem in
math departments.
It's historically
been a difficult area.
But it's always hard to prove.
It's a nebulous kind of thing.
They don't say, hey,
you can't have tenure
because you're a woman.
They'd get sued and
get killed for that.
So she had to get some
mat to back her up.
So what she did is she looked
into Berkeley's practices
and she found that in
all 22 departments,
every single department,
the percentage
of male PhD applicants
that were accepted
was higher than the percentage
of female PhD applicants
that were accepted.
Now you could understand some of
the departments accepting more
male PhDs than female PhDs.
But all 22?
What are the odds of that?
I mean, so the
immediate conclusion
is, well, that's clearly there's
sex discrimination going on
at Berkeley.
OK?
Well Berkeley took a look at
that and said, nothing good.
That doesn't look good for them.
But they did their own
study of PhD applicants.
And they said that if the
university as a whole--
look at the University as a
whole, actually, the women,
the females have a higher
acceptance rate for the PhD
Program than the men.
So look.
Berkeley said, we're
accepting more women
than men percentage-wise.
So how could we be
discriminating against women?
And this is where the same
argument the female faculty
member's making, But they're
saying as a university
as a whole, when you add
up all 22 departments.
Well, that sounds pretty good.
How could they be
discriminating?
OK.
So the question for you
guys, is it possible that
both sides we're
telling the truth,
that in every single department
the women have a lower
acceptance rate than men, but
on the university as a whole
the women are higher percentage?
It sounds like it's-- and just
to avoid any confusion here,
people only apply to one
department and they're only one
sex.
So you can't--
Carroll didn't apply.
[LAUGHTER]
How many people think that one
of the sides, actually, when
they look at the
studies was wrong,
that they're contradictory?
Nobody?
You've been in 6
over 2 too long.
How many people
think it's possible
that both sides were right?
Yeah.
All right.
So let's see how this works.
And to make it simple
I'm going to get down
to just two departments rather
than try to do data for all 22.
And I'm going to do not the
actual data but something
that's represents
what's going on.
OK.
So we're going to look
at the following events.
A is the event that the
applicant is admitted.
FCS is the event
that the applicant
is female and applying to CS.
FEE is the event
that the applicant
is female and applying to EE.
MCS is the event the
applicant is a male and CS.
And then finally we have MEE
is the event the applicant is
male and in EE.
So we're just going to
look at two departments
here and try to figure
out if it can happen
that in both departments
the women are worse off
but if you take the
union they're better off.
So the female professor's
argument effectively
is, the probability of being
admitted given that you're
a female in CS is less than the
probability of being admitted
given that you're a male at CS.
And same thing in EE.
Probability of being admitted
in EE if you're a female
is less than if you're a male.
OK?
Now Berkeley is saying
it's sort of the reverse.
The probability
that you're admitted
given that you're a female
in either department
is bigger than the probability
of being admitted if you're
a male in either department.
OK.
So we've now expressed
their arguments
as conditional
probabilities Any questions?
Can you sort of see why
this seems contradictory?
Not plus, union.
Because this is sort of
like-- these are just joined.
This is the sum of those.
And this is sort of
the sum of those.
And yet the inequality changed.
All right.
In fact, this is the logic
that we've just debunked over
there-- exactly that claim.
In fact, these are
not equal as the sum.
So let's do an example.
Say that-- let's
do it over here.
I'll put the real
values in over here.
Say that for women in
computer science, 0 out of 1
were admitted compared to
the men, were 50 out of 100
were admitted.
And then in EE, 70
out of 100 women
were admitted compared to the
men, which had 1 out of 1.
All right?
So as ratios, 70%
is less than 100%.
0% is less than 50.
Now if I look at the two
departments is a whole,
I get 70 over 101 is in fact
bigger than 51 over 101.
All right?
And so as a whole
women are a lot more
likely to be admitted even
though in each department
they're less likely
to be admitted.
OK?
So what went wrong with
the intuition, which
you didn't fall victim
to, but people often
do, that it shouldn't have
been possible given that?
What's going on
here that make it
so that it's not
a less than when
you look at the union
of the departments?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
they're weighted differently?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
They're weighted
very differently.
You got huge waves here.
Right?
So if I look at the average
of the percentages here,
well it's 35% for the women
versus 75% for the men.
So the average of the percentage
is just what you'd think.
35 is less than 75.
But I've got huge weightings
on these guys, which changes
the numbers quite dramatically.
So it all depends
how you count it.
Actually, who do you
think had a better-- Yeah.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Who won the lawsuit?
Actually, the woman
won the lawsuit.
And which argument
would you buy now?
You've got two arguments.
Which one would you
believe if either?
Which one?
I mean, now if I look
at exactly this data
I might side-- I might
side with Berkeley
looking at these numbers.
Then again, when you think about
all 22 departments and the fact
they weren't this
lopsided, not so good.
So in the end Berkeley lost.
I'm going to see another
example in a minute
where it's even more clear
which side to believe in.
But it really depends
on the numbers
as to which one you
might, if you had to vote,
which way you'd vote.
Here's another example.
This is from a newspaper article
on which airlines are best
to fly because they have
the best on-time rates.
And in this case they were
comparing American Airlines
and America West,
looking at on-time rates.
And here's the data they
showed for the two airlines.
Here's American Airlines.
Here's America West.
And they took five cities,
LA, Phoenix, San Diego,
San Francisco, and Seattle.
And then you looked
at the number on time,
the number of flights, and then
the rate, percentage on time.
And then same thing here.
Number on time, number
of flights, and the rate.
So I'm just going to give
you the numbers here.
So they had 500 out of 560 for
a rate of 89%, 220 over 230
for 95, 210 over 230 for
92%, 500 over 600 for 83%,
and then Seattle.
They had a lot of flights.
That's where they're-- we
have a hub of 2,200 for 86%.
And if you added them all up,
they got 3,300 out of 3,820
for 87% on time.
Now the data for
American West looks
something like the following.
In LA it's 700 out
of 800 for 87%.
they're based in Phoenix.
They got a zillion
flights there.
4,900 out of 5,300 for 92%.
And 400 over 450 for 89%, 320,
over 450, 71%, 200 over 260
for 77%.
And then you add all them up.
And you've got 6,520
over 7,260 for 90%.
So the newspaper concluded
and literally said
that American West
is the better airline
to fly because they're
on-time rate is much better.
It's 90% versus 87%.
What do you think?
Which airline would you
fly looking at that data?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I know
which one I'd fly.
It looks like America
West is better.
Every single city, American
Airlines is better.
92 versus 89.
Everywhere it's
better by a bunch.
83 versus 71.
86 versus 77.
Every single city, American
Airlines is better.
Yet, America West
is better overall.
And that's what
the newspaper said.
They went on this.
But of course, no matter
where you're going
you're better off with
American Airlines.
All right?
Now what happened here?
The waiting.
In fact, America West
flies out of Phoenix
where the weather's great.
So you get a higher on-time rate
when in a good-weather city.
And they got most of
their flights there.
American Airlines got a
lot of flights in Seattle
where the weather sucks
and you're always delayed.
All right?
And so they look
worse on average
because so many of their
flights are in a bad city
and so many of America
West are in a good city.
All right?
So it makes America
West look better
when in fact, in this case, it's
absolutely clear whose better.
American Airlines is
better, every single city.
All right.
That's why Mark
Twain said, "There's
three kinds of lies-- lies,
damned lies, and statistics."
We'll see more
examples next time.